okay what are you doing it stops the
suit
from riding up i've actually tried that
hairspray does not work i use something
much stronger
hi my name is chesley crist i'm a former
miss usa miss usa 2019.
today we're going to be watching pageant
scenes from tv and film and judging how
real they are
oh my god my tag costume's done you
heard me where is it
you know get it all right i might even
take it i've competed in
i don't know almost 20 pageants in my
entire lifetime i've
literally never seen something unfold
that way you may see
some uh sort of underlying cattiness
between people but and not anything that
that would be different from what you
might see in like a regular workplace
like i've heard at one international
competition somebody put
gum on somebody's dress you know the
rules all talent costumes have to be
okay by glad it's before the pageant her
having to approve costumes
that is a real thing they would have to
see your swimsuit to make sure that you
know your swimsuit is appropriate for
the competition
for miss usa and for miss universe
obviously those competitions are
televised
a specific person um takes photos of us
and every single outfit we wear on stage
so that they can approve it for
television my jacket
take it because you know i got my
costume okayed a month ago before the
pageant you could wear it
come on one of the things that people
miss out on pageants is
really how kind and generous most of the
contestants
truly are i've actually been in a state
competition
where a woman signed up to compete and
she didn't know how to do her own makeup
and so there were like four or five
girls surrounding her
literally doing her makeup for her at
this competition i've seen girls you
know
yeah give each other you know shoes to
wear or jewelry to wear
yeah i'd give it a six generally um
women who compete in pageants
are so sweet and genuinely nice and
they're like a small fraction every now
and then you run into it that are catty
[Music]
miss congeniality is like every pageant
girls
movie we like quote this movie this is
obviously like sort of a souped-up
version of what really happened
but in a lot of cases when you win you
have a committee
that is there to support you so when i
won my state pageant
we literally had like a retreat weekend
they brought in
an interview coach who gave us private
interview sessions went over our resumes
with us
we had a makeup artist who brought in
makeup that matched our skin tones and
gave us a makeup lesson
we had a self-defense coach who came in
and talked to us so it felt
a lot like this in one weekend hi um
well my uh roommate's asleep that
absolutely is real i've had a roommate
at my state competition at miss usa and
at miss universe i've had a roommate
that's it excuse me i am in the middle
of a rem cycle over here
some days you know you had to be ready
by maybe six or seven o'clock in the
morning and if you think about hair and
makeup before then you're up pretty
early
you know you try to get as much rest as
possible but during pageant week
sometimes it really just isn't possible
so i think i got
five hours of sleep the the night before
miss usa
okay what are you doing it stops the
suit
from riding up i think he's spraying
hair spray on her bottom
i've actually tried that hairspray does
not work i use something much stronger
called firm grip
which i think is the same product that
baseball players spray in their mitts so
that they're more sticky and they can
catch balls easier
so it's very heavy duty product but
there's other types of glues that we use
to keep your bikini on
otherwise your swimsuit may end up
riding up and you may have like a wedgie
and you know your
butt cheeks may be hanging out of your
swimsuit when you walk and you don't
want that obviously
what hemorrhoid ointment it's for the
little baggies under your eyes
i haven't really tried i think some
people talk about using vaseline on your
teeth to make sure that your smile
um it stays on sort of when you're on
stage i've never done that
i think it might make it more difficult
to talk or you might have products
you know in in your teeth and for those
close-ups on television you can actually
see some of that new jersey
so our sashes are usually taped to our
shoulders on stage so that they don't
fall off of our shoulders
our sarongs when we compete in swimsuit
after we're done competing and we're
just standing i remember somebody came
and literally tied the sarong into my
swimsuit
so that it wouldn't come off when they
were making like the top 10 announcement
so tons of sticky things on our bodies
turn around there's only women backstage
my dressers have always been women
our chaperones are always women but
obviously you know pageants have
continued to evolve and we do want to
make sure that it's a safe space for
people and that people feel comfortable
describe your perfect date
april 25th because it's not too
hot not too cold this poor woman
i have to say onstage question is by far
the most difficult and stressful part of
any competition partly because you're
speaking on stage in front of a lot of
people a lot of the times
it's the last area of competition you
usually have a really difficult question
about some you know controversial or
polarizing issue
and usually you also have a time limit
if you've completed a page and you
haven't messed up your onstage question
have you really competed in the pageant
[Music]
and the competitions i've been in
they've typically provided
food especially if you're there for two
weeks obviously we need food and
usually it's really healthy food a lot
of women are generally eating
you know really healthy when you're at a
competition because you're going to
compete in a swimsuit and you want to
make sure that
whatever diet or exercise you put into
your prep is still there
when you're on stage i would give it
like an eight and a half or nine
and i like that at the end of the day
miss congeniality
uh portrayed women and you know that a
lot of these women were really nice
they were real they were imperfect and
that's actually what happened
elmo ella richter stress album
there's a lot of coaching that comes
along with pageantry i love the little
wave though there's actually like a
thing it's like elbow elbow wrist
wrist touch your pearls blow a kiss
that's sort of like the
the sort of pageant way we don't wave
like that anymore we just wave like
regular people either you guys like do
one of these or like wave like this
or you give like the big the big wave
when you win this is the big wave where
you've got your
hand all the way up in the air that's a
thing turn your body slowly very good
eye contact here
there are certain poses that are
specific to pageantry can i show you
some of them
so there's there's one pose that a lot
here will go in my white space there we
go
that a lot of girls like to do in
evening gown where you pose like this
and then you put a hand
like right here on your thigh slash leg
area
and so it's supposed to be like this a
lot of people do like the model t
where you've got like your foot your
front foot like this and your back foot
like this
it's supposed to give you this more
hourglass shape a lot of girls nowadays
do like the legs apart pose
so you're standing i don't know if you
can see my legs but like you know you've
got your legs out like this
one leg would be kind of in front of the
other so that you look longer your legs
look leaner and everything
all of these are very specific to
pageantry so like the kitty pageants
like you know the toddlers and tiaras
pageants
that kind of posing is very different
from what you would do at miss usa oh
yeah i would give this a 5. because i
can't say there was a whole lot that i
saw in these clips
that actually happens it the way that
it's depicted here
butter is in still water and you
are miss tulsa somebody from her team is
like photoshopping one of her pictures
that happens too
there's been a former miss usa who
talked about somebody from her team
had photoshopped one of her photos and
like made her look really skinny and
really tall
so she was at miss universe and you know
she's got this photoshop picture she
looks really good
and then she saw some other pictures
that some of the
um on location photographers had taken
that obviously weren't photoshopped
and she she said that she felt bad
because she was like did i gain weight
since i've been here
and she talks to her old team member and
they're like well i photoshopped your
photo
so she's like i wish i would have at
least known that or maybe i wish you
wouldn't have done that so that i at
least had a real
uh you know perspective on how my own
body looks but it definitely happens i
hope people know that
you know we're not perfect obviously we
want to put our best foot forward
but just know you know photoshopping and
filtering happens
[Music]
there's tons of people backstage or it
can be at least just as hectic as it
looks here
there are hair and makeup people who are
going around and doing touch-ups there's
hairspray all over there are people like
adjusting
your costume or your gown or your
swimsuit
there are you know members of the
production team back there that are
counting down on their radios
i just try to focus on the task at hand
and compartmentalize what's going on
think about where am i standing where do
i go after that if they call my name
where do i step two neck yeah
i'd give this like a like a strong eight
and five six seven eight
the difficulty of the dances just varies
by the pageant low-key
we had an audition they didn't they
don't call it an audition but loki it
kind of is
what the choreographers did for us is
they
taught all of us i think it was like
maybe two or three eight counts of a
dance
and then they lined us up in like rows
of six or whatever and made us do the
dance
you know sort of one row by one and so
some of the more difficult dance moves
they gave to people who could pick it up
quickly
and some of the maybe walking patterns
uh they gave to people who were less
coordinated
and it has like no effect on who wins
you lied to me
you just lied you lied straight to my
face
is this who you are i've never seen a
parent
randomly interrupt the middle of a
pageant and come backstage and try to
take somebody home i think that would be
way out of the ordinary nothing that
it's never happened i've just personally
never seen it happen
and we have security backstage and so
you're not gonna be able to just bust in
the backstage area
but as a teen yeah you would need some
some level of parental consent
um pageants can be pretty costly and so
as a team if you don't have a job you're
gonna
you're gonna need your parents help
either to pay for your entry fees or to
pay for
you know your makeup your wardrobe now
as far as like having family members not
know that could definitely happen
i remember when i competed my final year
at miss
north carolina usa i didn't know if i
would win and i gotta tell you
there is nothing um that puts more
pressure on you than knowing that your
friends and family
have you know driven or flown from far
away to watch you compete have
paid for hotel rooms have paid for
tickets are out there rooting for you
and then have you not win it's terrible
for this one i would give it a seven the
parent coming backstage is
is not super realistic here we have
leslie's custom scorecard
with categories such as presentation
intelligence knowledge of herstory so
the judging criteria for
every competition is different some
judges
have scores that they'll put down either
in you know swimsuit or
talent or on stage question you have a
score from
like five to ten i've actually judged a
state competition
in the miss universe organization and i
really liked that we didn't assign
people
numbers um so for swimsuit for example
i wouldn't give someone a 10 out of 10.
you would just make selections
if only 15 contestants get to advance in
the swimsuit competition you would watch
everybody compete all 40 in the
preliminary competition
and then you would literally just select
15 people that you thought should
advance in swimsuit and i volunteer
at the children's hospital
[Applause]
my girl trish is talented unless a judge
makes
you know really inappropriate comments
or something i don't you know
i don't see why they would kick them off
just for you know not being a good judge
what makes a good judge or a bad judge i
mean
you know i i think like i said it's
really subjective
and you know what somebody may
appreciate in one contestant somebody
may
not be able to stand we don't get cash
this is for a fence
well it won't cover a whole fence but it
will defray the cost considerably
and a system like the miss america
organization no matter what level you're
competing at you get some sort of
scholarship miss america gets like a 50
000
scholarship and miss america is a
salaried employee
so you also get you know additional
prizes
and stuff on top of that miss usa and
miss universe we are also salaried
employees
of the miss universe organization we
also have housing we lived in a
high-rise in manhattan in new york
um for the the term that we were
titleholders
this one's kind of low yes i would rank
this one pretty low maybe like uh
three out of ten i did like how they
depicted one of the
competitors i mean she said that she you
know she talked about her volunteerism
that she was a student
[Applause]
so this particular scene was 1970s the
protesters were part of the women's
liberation movement
and this was at miss world if something
like that happened now i
i would assume that security would
probably remove those people
obviously you know voicing your opinion
and
protesting is an important exercise but
we also have a competition going on we
want the women who are given an
opportunity to make a change and make a
difference
but we have had something um similar to
this happen
a different kind of protest during the
election cycle for 2016. former
president donald trump then
owned the miss universe organization and
you may remember that he made some
awful disparaging statements was talking
about immigrants crossing the border and
just was disparaging them
the network that owned the competition i
think
decided not to air the competition on
television the celebrity judges that
were lined up for the competition
pulled out um i think the hosts pulled
out the talent pulled out
and and rightfully so right we have to
say that we don't stand for these kind
of comments i don't stand for those
kinds of comments and nobody wants to be
associated with that
so you know on that end that was an
important move but on the other end
you have these women who are title
holders who also don't stand for that
these women have prepared for a year and
now we're like out of a competition
because this man decided to make these
awful statements
there were similar protests when you
know miss america and miss usa were
happening
uh and in the states and there were many
times when women would talk about
pageants and say that they you know
weren't appropriate for the times or
that they were disparaging or
objectifying to women
obviously i don't believe that but i
think it's important that women
and people in general voice their
opinions and try to push for progress
the way that they see fit
there are people who believe that
pageants are just about showing up and
being pretty
i've actually had someone say that to me
when i was a state title holder i was
standing backstage at an awards show
then this woman walked up to me and she
said it must be so hard just showing up
and being pretty
being miss usa opened up so many new
opportunities for me
it gave me the opportunity to speak
about issues that were
incredibly important to me like you know
black lives matter the resurgence of the
movement last summer
i talked about you know immigration
reform
is miss grenada
your mind goes totally blank at least
minded and i remember
forgetting where the cameras were so
you're supposed to like look out into
the stage so people can get your
reaction
instead i'm holding hands with my first
runner up who's miss new mexico
and i literally just collapsed into her
arms and i'm sort of like bending down
like this and because i was doing that
there are no reaction shots literally
all you're looking at is the side of my
head this is me when i won
so if you win make sure you look at the
camera
[Music]
i certainly knew about uh the landmark
title holders
in the miss universal organization like
for example carol gist who was miss usa
in 1990
she was the first black uh miss usa
and which which is crazy to think that
in in the 70s you know we
we already had a woman of color who had
won miss world so i feel like this world
and miss universe were obviously
far more advanced when it came to racial
diversity
than some of the competitions in the
states even today we're still dealing
with some of those issues we're still
still dealing with you know colorism and
in competitions we're still dealing with
women feeling like we have to do code
switching
in competitions rather than just being
able to be our authentic selves
look i'll give it like an eight for the
time yeah
i've seen some pretty interesting
talents i can't say that i've seen some
very dangerous ones
i think there's been like um luggage
packing
years ago um the current miss america i
think she did a science experiment for
her talent
at miss north carolina and miss america
those are that's sort of the system that
still has talent
there are always you know tons of tap
dancers there are always you know tons
of musicians
singers oh my so many singers you would
almost
never see somebody doing the same song
at one competition especially when you
get to the state and the national level
which is all about meeting and exceeding
generally you cannot see i've never been
able to see
um into the audience that well but as
far as like being able to communicate
messages back and forth
i don't think that that would be
possible especially because you know on
stage question is usually timed and you
just don't have time to sit there and
watch somebody read their lips
i can't say that anything from this is
very realistic other than
you know a woman wearing a pretty dress
on stage i'm gonna give this one a two
out of ten